nun denkt dass nur ein trick gerade gibt
es hier sogar licht leute herzlich
willkommen
zu meinem sehr spontanen video eheleute
was geht ab ich hoffe natürlich euch
jetzt gut und zwar ich weiß nicht ich
jetzt kamen zwei tage kein video
ich war noch mal unterwegs und zwar in
österreich am achensee oder so ist das
ist wirklich ein sehr schöner ort hier
und ich habe mir gedacht weil ich
wirklich von dem hotel zumal sehr sehr
beeindruckt so heiß ich glaube das ist
echtes schönste hotel wo ich jemals war
an dieser stelle mal ganz kurz schöne
grüße an regard to jah würde ich mal
sagen danke und ich habe mir gedacht
bevor ich einfach das nicht filme film
ich es einfach mal das ganze hat aber
auch noch einen anderen grund und zwar
haben wir hier noch ein video gedreht
für meine reise kanal beziehungsweise
unseren heinzl kann dann findet ihr
nämlich ganz oben die überschreibung und
da wird auch ein extrem cooles video von
mir folgen das wollte ich nur am anfang
sofort mal sagen und jetzt zeige ich
euch ganz kurz das hotelzimmer dann
zeige ich euch noch den pool bereich
weil er ist auch echt richtig cool hier
die aussicht ist echt hammer folgen der
serie hat seine kasse habe also es ist
ein sehr schöner bart und wir fangen an
bei der toilette und die sieht so aus
das finde ich immer gut wenn die
toilette sich im bad ist ein hotelzimmer
man kann hier so gar nicht über
abschließen und guter wollen wir aber
gar nicht so viel zeit verlieren dann
geht man hier weiter ins badezimmer das
ist eigentlich ja gut das ist jetzt ist
jetzt natürlich
ja ganz typisches bad wie man zu kennen
wir haben einen wunderschönen spiegel
aber ich habe noch gar kein bier
spielzeit gemacht muss ich noch machen
vielleicht ja gut dann haben wir hier
kann man ja mal noch eine badewanne mit
einer dusche aber ist halt auch das
kennt man ja jahres typische halt kennt
man ja
wundert euch würde nicht über die
heutigen film verhältnisse das ist etwas
provisorisch gut einnahmen nach oben zu
rutschen jetzt gehen wir ein bisschen in
die richtung am besten gehst du erst mal
rückwärts so ein bisschen struth ja hier
hat man ein bett ziemlich groß ist
bequem ins bett ja es ist echt ein sehr
schönes bett an dieser stelle nochmal
kurz hier falls ihr das schon gesehen
habt und euch fragte was ist was hat er
dafür polieren am 28 april kommt neuer
merge von mir beziehungsweise mein
erster eigener culic wenn man das thema
so sieht also schreibt euch das hinter
die ohren traktion im kalender ein
wollte ich nur sagen ja das hier ist das
bleibt das kasse ist hier auf dem
fernseher
ich hatte noch nie ein hotelzimmer wo
man sky hatte und ich bin ja einen
fußball feiern also ich koche sehr gerne
fußball und wenn man hier fußball gucken
kann
dann vergisst man schon fast dass man im
urlaub ist und aktiver fußball also das
war nicht auch echt bemerkenswert nach
österreich im fußball zu gucken ja so
wir gehen jetzt mal hier weiter und das
lustige ist das hatte ich auch noch nie
es gibt einfach einen begehbaren
kleiderschrank und ich frage mich so
welcher mensch macht urlaub und braucht
einen begehbaren kleiderschrank
hier geht so gar nicht an
hier kann man seine sachen aufnehmen
also wenn man so drei vier ist lohnt
sich das vielleicht ansonsten hier haben
wir noch was ist das eigentlich
die decken oder so und bücher acht keine
ahnung
auf jeden fall war ich davon auch
wirklich sehr beeindruckt so dann sind
wir hier aufs zimmer gekommen und hier
stand ja weil ich das vorher noch nie
hatte sowas bin ich nicht gewohnt ich
bin kein luxusurlaub wegen meiner
ja die ist auf jeden fall hatten wir
hier eine sektflasche mit einem netten
willkommensgruß de ist immer noch nicht
leer
ich denke sowieso nicht mehr gerne
alkohol deswegen auch mein merge dann
hat man hier noch ein schönes lampen
ambiente im ganzen zimmer
das zimmer ist wirklich sehr groß wenn
man das sieht man hier so sieht immer
noch ein stückchen weiter nach hinten
so also wirklich ein sehr großes zimmer
wo man sich ja man hat genug platz das
finde ich immer schade wenn so ein
hotelzimmer nur zwölf quadratmeter hat
wenn man an den kopf so vor einem bäcker
4 war das nicht der fall wir kommen
wirklich sehr sehr gut übernachten
richtig richtig geil das cooles wir
haben ein zimmer zur seeseite raus wir
sind ja hier in österreich werden hier
berge und wir haben einen cast isensee
deswegen leute gehen wir hier kurz raus
wie man das ich hoffe man kann es gut
erkennen
ach so das ist übrigens hinten was eine
schöne aussicht das kannst du einmal
vielleicht darum filme ein wunder
wunderbarer sie also hier kann man sehr
gut frühstücken und hier unten haben wir
noch einen teich mit fischen da hinten
ist ein kleiner whirlpool wo ich auch
noch gestern abend drin war
und da oben liegt noch schnee da liegt
noch schnee ich wollte auch wenig in den
see springen nur der hat zwölf grad oder
zehn grad bei 20.000 leicht springen
schreien ja weil schon jetzt zeige ich
euch noch kurz im poolbereich weil er es
auch sehr sehr cool und viel spaß so
leute das ist der pool war ich finde das
ist echt heftig also es sieht richtig
schön aus
und das cool ist der pool geht einfach
bis nach draußen und keine ahnung wie
aber hier ist das wasser bereits da
obwohl es keine trennwand gibt so leute
und wenn man dann hier weitergeht kann
man noch in einen anderen bereich nicht
draußen so und dann kann man hier runter
gehen
und da gibt es auch noch draußen und das
wasser das ist ziemlich warm recht
entspannend und ich frage mich immer wie
lange das mal einfach mit noch was drin
oder ich hoffe man nicht und genau die
paar meter hinter ist sie ja leute das
war's mit diesem video ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen kleine kultur sehr spontan
danke nochmal an weekend am 28 april
kommt dieser merger aus ich könnte ja
gerne in die kommentare schreiben
wie es findet wir haben hier einen pulli
ein sehr cooler qualität dazu aber noch
einiges in den folgenden videos wir
sehen uns war 35 fenster geschaut und ja
das war's ich hoffe ich muss nicht in
den see springen